.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, AMBASSADOR.
>> APPRECIATED.
>> THE U.S. AND ALLIES SANCTIONS
ON RUSSIA'S OLIGARCHS RUSSIA'S
WEALTHIEST MOST INFLUENTIAL
OLIGARCHS TARGETING THE UK, THEY
FED STRONG ON THIS.
ASSETS FROZEN IN BAND FROM THEIR
COUNTRY.
UNTIL NOW, THEY'VE LIVED
LAVISHLY, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS, CARS, TALKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING YOU WANT FROM YACHT
TWO BIG PLANES.
JOINING US NOW, COULD EVENTUALLY
BE A VALUABLE SPEAKER AND A
WRITER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, DOING A
GREAT JOB.
YOU HAVE A BOOK COMING OUT ALSO.
THEY'VE GOT SEVEN OLIGARCHS
SANCTIONED BY THE UK, BASICALLY
TAKING THEIR STUFF.
WHY DO OLIGARCHS RUN TO THE UK?
>> SEVERAL THINGS, IF YOU WANT
TO STORE MONEY SOMEWHERE, YOU
WANT SOMEWHERE STABLE, COMMON
LAW COUNTRIES IN STABLE PLACES
TO STORE MONEY.
THE SECOND THING IS UNDOUBTEDLY
THE LAST 20 YEARS, THE UK
GOVERNMENT TURNING A BLIND EYE
FROM THE RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS.
NOT JUST YOST BUT THEY BOUGHT
FOOTBALL CLUBS, THEY BOUGHT
NEWSPAPERS, A MAN WHO IS NOW A
FRIEND OF MANY POLITICIANS IN
THE UK, FOUGHT THE INDEPENDENT
NEWSPAPER AND THEY NEED SAVING,
SOME OF THE OPERATIVES CAME
ABOUT THE PAPERS AND PEOPLE
LIKED IT, I THINK IT WAS LONG
AGO SHOULD HAVE BEEN, YOU JUST
LOOK AND THINK HOW DID YOU THINK
IT WAS EVER A GOOD IDEA?
>> THE CEO, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE CHAIRMAN OF VPP BANK, AND
YOU HAVE HIGH PROFILE GUY,
ABRAMOVICH WHO WANTED
CHAMPIONSHIP AND NOT EVERYBODY
WANTS TO BUY IT.
HERE IS THE THING, THEY'VE TAKEN
THEIR MONEY FROM THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE AND THEY KEPT IT
CONCENTRATED, THEY'VE MADE IT
RIGHT FOR SOMEONE TO STEP UP
LIKE PUTIN TO TAKE OVER AND HE
STEPPED TURNS AROUND AND SAY I
KEEP 50% AND YOU KEEP YOUR
MONEY.
CAN THEY PUT PRESSURE ON PUTIN
OR DOES HE HAVE ALL THE POWER
AND SECURITY?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS HAS BECOME
CLEAR, A LOT OF POLITICIANS PUT
PAVERS AROUND THEM PARTICULARLY
WITH THE OWNER, THESE PEOPLE
HAVE NOT JUST THEIR OWN MONEY,
THESE PEOPLE DON'T ONLY OWN
THEIR OWN MONEY, ABRAMOVICH HAS
FORGOT.
WHY DOES ANYONE NEED FOR?
IT SEEMS THEY ARE HOLDING MONEY
FOR OTHER PEOPLE AS WELL, THINGS
FOR OTHER PEOPLE, YACHTS FOR
OTHER PEOPLE.
WE GET BACK TO IS ONE OF THE
THINGS IN THIS THE WAY IN WHICH
LATIMER PUTIN STORES HIS WEALTH
FOR WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS?
GO FOR THE OLIGARCHS, SEES THE
THINGS THEY HAVE SO THESE PEOPLE
SEE VLADIMIR PUTIN NOT AS THEIR
SAVIOR BUT THEIR CURSE.
IF YOU CAN TURN THAT AROUND,
MAYBE SOMETHING CHANGES NOT JUST
IN UKRAINE.
>> OTHER HUNDREDS OF OLIGARCHS?
>> A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER.
I THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD THING
FOR GENERAL PEACE IN THE WORLD.
>> AND I THINK THE TAKE AWAY,
WHY DOES ANYONE NEED SEVEN
YACHTS?
THANKS SO MUCH,